i was sitting in my quarterly leadership
meeting where everyone had flown into
vegas
for two days to talk about the next
quarter and our goals for the company
and i stood there and i was listening to
what they were saying and i wanted to
light my head on fire what transpired
next was a problem-solving process that
i want to share with you because
it unlocked
10 million to 12 million dollars in
annual revenue for us that we had not
been able to unlock for two quarters
because of one simple misdiagnosed
problem and so the purpose of this video
is to hopefully get you to one avoid
making that mistake but two be able to
use this framework so that you can solve
the right problems in your business
so if you guys don't know my name uh my
name is austin mosey i own
acquisition.com it's portfolio companies
do about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you um and the reason i
make these videos is because a lot of
people are broke and i don't want you to
be one of them all right so
inside of our quarterly meeting for two
quarters in a row my sales manager set
the goal that they wanted to add six
more outbound reps two quarters in a row
quarter came
quarter left quarter came quarter left
this is the third time that i've been
hearing them make this goal
and everyone was nodding their heads and
writing them down and it seemed like
everything was hunky-dory
and i stopped and i was like
guys we've had this goal for for two
quarters why do we expect it to be any
different this time
to set the same goal and nothing's going
to happen and for context the reason i
said 10 to 12 million is because every
outbound rep generates about two million
dollars a year in revenue for my
business and so for me to have six more
reps is about 12 million so i'm not just
pulling that out of nowhere that's where
it comes from back to the story i asked
him i was like
why weren't you able to do this it's
like well you know we lost a couple reps
this last quarter even though we hired
some new ones and we pretty much have
the same amount as we we had before and
i was like and is that what happened the
quarter before that too he's like well
yeah i was like then how are you going
to solve this problem
it's like um
i don't know
and then it hit me i had been driving
this guy and putting my pressure on this
guy when he was not the constraint of
the system let me explain in every
system you have potential and you have
constraints
most entrepreneurs spend all their time
trying to add potential to their
business thinking that they are solving
the constraint but we will always grow
any system will grow up to its
constraint and no further and so right
now your business has a constraint you
have to identify it and what makes macro
speed happen is not is not the
frenziness and the frenetic energy it's
knowing which problems to solve in what
order and the example i'm going to give
you is showing you exactly why that
didn't happen for one of my companies
for this specific channel we were
marketing on which is outbound had we
identified this problem two quarters ago
we would have added 10 million to our
top line for this year which we won't
have so instead we're going to get one
quarter's worth of that so maybe add 2
million or 2 and a half million to top
line when we should have added 10 or 12
because of this one problem and from the
outside people are going to say oh well
it's because of x y and z but they
didn't diagnose the root problem do you
know what it was i'll tell you so i then
turned to my hr director and i said
how many how many people are you sending
the sales manager per week she was like
well i sent him about uh one qualified
candidate a week and i was like okay
how many interviews does it take you to
send one qualified candidate she said it
takes five i was like okay manager how
many of these final interviews does it
take for you to get one person hired he
was like four i was like so it takes us
20 people that we got to get through to
get one new outbound run he was like
yeah it's like okay now given the churn
that we had in the last quarter and two
quarters because just fyi for everybody
frontline positions in general tend to
turn more than manager and leadership
positions just this name of the game and
i was like okay so what is our churn in
that position he was like it's about 20
a quarter i was like okay understood now
simple math here if we have 10 people
who are working outbound that's not the
number but let's just say it's 10. and
we lose 20 then it means we're losing
two people a quarter if right now the
process that you have gets us one new
outbound rep per month and we're losing
to a quarter that means we would net one
new person per quarter that is going to
be very short of our goal of six so what
do we need to do
we need to fix the actual hiring process
in order to meet the goal and so what we
did was we actually i asked the hr
director i said why are we doing these
one-on-one she's like well i thought we
had to do that miscommunication right
it's all it was there's a
miscommunication so we don't need that
for this position what she now did the
solution to this problem was that she's
setting up she's still running the ad
she's still organizing the interviews
but she set them all up for the sales
manager to do group interviews and now
he
can do five group interviews for one
hour per week and now he can pick
one or two of those people and get them
onboarded quickly and he can start
hiring he will be able to hit his goal
in that way
and so the reason i tell the story is
because i just missed out on a bunch of
revenue that i should have been able to
make because we were solving the wrong
problem all of the focus was on the
sales manager and and who he was
bringing in and how he was training them
rather than because that wasn't the
constraint of the system rather than
what is the acquisition process for
talent and so i'll give you a framework
that i wrote down somewhere that i'll
probably share in another video but it's
something called the quad marketing
calendar most people have
no marketing calendar smart people have
one or two marketing calendars so the
first marketing calendar and you can
draw this you know what i'll do for you
right now alright so the quad marketing
calendar looks like this here you've got
internal and you've got external so here
you have employees and you've got
prospects
internally which is this way you should
be marketing to your employees
so that you tell them about the vision
and about the mission about why you do
what you do
this has to happen all the time so that
people continue to want to work for you
internally to your prospects which are
now customers over here you need to
continue to market them to get them to
buy
again and again right we need to keep
them to keep buying
over here in external
for prospects you need to get people to
become customers so we're marketing
externally most people understand this
one this is the one that most people do
most people don't do this one most
people definitely don't do this one and
i'll tell you the one that people miss
the most
this one
is that they don't have an acquisition
process for getting new talent so just
like you
run ads generate leads nurture leads set
appointments sell
fulfill
you should be able to
run
ads for new
employees you should be generating leads
you should be working those leads you
should be setting
interviews which are sales you make job
offers just like you make normal offers
and then the onboarding experience that
you have for a customer is the
onboarding experience that you have in
parallel
with an employee and then just like you
continue to ascend and resell
your
customers you ascend
and continue to manage
your employees these are parallel
processes that happen in every business
and most people don't know about it and
you heard about it here first
at the world's best youtube channel in
the world with the the handsomest and
most uh sickly now rona ridden uh
youtuber out there and this is called
the quad bargaining calendar and it was
because we were missing this framework
my hr director did not understand this
framework that we lost out on 10 to 12
million revenue and i don't want you to
do that all right and so the reason i
made this video is so that you can
recognize which of these four in the
quad marketing calendar you are not
using
so that you can shore up that part of
your business and ultimately scale it
and make all of your wildest dreams come
true all right my name is alex from
rosie like i said on acquisition.com
i've got nothing to sell you hope you
enjoyed this video and i'll guys i'll
see you guys the next one keep being
awesome bye